I want to start off with talking to you about
three things that keep me up at night, right?
Three things: the first, and it may be, you
know, very common for you too, is climate change.
Climate change absolutely keeps me up at night.
The second thing that keeps me up at night
is that people may have no idea that an artificial
intelligence is making a decision that directly
impacts their lives - what percentage interest
rate you get on your loan, whether you get that
job that you applied for, whether your kid gets
into that college that they really want to go to.
Today AI is making decisions
that directly impact you.
The third thing that keeps me up at night
is: even when people know that an AI
is making a decision about them, they may assume
that because it's not a fallible human with bias,
that somehow the AI is going to make a decision
that's morally or ethically squeaky clean,
and that could not be farther from the truth.
So, if you think about organizations
and what happens over 80% of the time
proof of concepts associated with artificial
intelligence actually gets stalled in testing
and more often than not it is because people
do not trust the results from that AI model.
So, we're going to talk a lot about trust,
and when thinking about trust (I’m going to
switch colors here) there's actually five pillars.
OK, when you're thinking about what does it
take to earn trust in an artificial intelligence
that's being made by your organization or being
procured by your organization: five pillars.
The first thing to be thinking about
is fairness. How can you ensure
that the AI model is fair towards everybody in
particular historically underrepresented groups.
OK, the second is explainable is your AI model
explainable such that you'd be able to tell
somebody, an end user, what data sets were being
used in order to curate that model, what methods,
what expertise was the data lineage in provenance
associated with, how that model was trained.
The third: robustness. Can you assure end users
that nobody can hack such an AI model such that
a person could disadvantage
willfully other people and or
make the results of that model benefit
one particular person over another?
The fourth is transparency. Are you telling
people, right off the bat, that the AI model
is indeed being used to make
that decision and are you giving
people access to a fact sheet or metadata so
that they can learn more about that model?
And the fifth one is: are you
assuring people's data privacy?
So, those are the five pillars. OK, now
IBM has come up with three principles
when thinking about AI in an organization.
The first being that the purpose of artificial
intelligence is really meant to be to augment
human intelligence not to replace it.
The second is that data and the insights from
those data belong to the creator alone
OK, and the third is that AI systems, and I would
opine the entire AI life cycle, really should be
transparent and explainable, right?
So, so, those are the five pillars.
Now, the next thing I want you to remember as
you're thinking about this space of earning
trust and artificial intelligence is that this is
not a technological challenge. It can't be solved
with just throwing tools and tech over some kind
of fence. This is a socio-technological challenge.
"Social" meaning people, people, people.
Socio-technological challenges because
it's a socio-technological challenge it
must be addressed holistically, okay?
"Holistically" meaning there's three major things
that you should think about. I mentioned people,
people the culture of your organization, right?
Thinking about the diversity of your teams,
you know, your data science team. Who is curating
that data to train that model? How many women are
on that team? How many minorities are on that
team, right? Think about diversity. I don't
know if you've ever heard of the the "wisdom of
crowds". That's actually a proven mathematical
theory: the more diverse your group of people,
the less chance for error, and that is absolutely
true in the realm of artificial intelligence.
The second thing is process or governance, right?
What is it that use your organization
what are you going to promise your
both your employees as well as the market with
respect to what standards you're going to stand by
for your AI model in terms of things like fairness
and explainability accountability, etc., right?
And the third area is tooling, right? What are
the tools, AI engineering methods, frameworks
that you can use in order to ensure these
things, ensure those five pillars, and we're
gonna do a deep dive into that as well, but the
next show that I’m going to be running with you
we're actually going to be talking about this
one. About people and culture. So, stay tuned.
If you like this video and series, please
comment below stay tuned for more videos
that are part of this series and to
get updates please like and subscribe.